well to tokyo and some breaking news  from the olympics and some great news uh  for  team gb on day 10  of the competition uh great britain's  laura collette tom mcewen and oliver  towne and have won  gold in the eventing at the tokyo  olympics that has been confirmed  in the past a few seconds so that will  take uh team gb's  medal hall in gold's only 2  11 33 medals in total now and there has  been another development this morning  that  simone biles has been named in the  starting  lineup for the beam tomorrow this of  course  comes after the american gymnast who won  four gold medals  at the 2016 games pulled out of a series  of competitions  after deciding to prioritize her mental  health